you
hi everyone it's Jerry Aman chess calms
tactics trainer and going to do another
group of three puzzles and simply share
my thoughts along the way okay I know
the answer to this one I haven't seen
this one before but okay point playing
is black.here there's a threat against
h7 but not only that there's an
unprotected rook additionally we have a
check against the king so I'm thinking
we could stop any threat against our
rook first by playing Queen b8 with
check we defend our rook and then after
h6 the knight is trapped yeah no good
squares for him to go to I am concerned
some though because can't we can't we
first go here anyhow oh no we can't see
what I'm doing right here is just
wondering if there's any difference
between the move order my ID is queen v8
and then h6 and so I then questioned can
we play h6 first and only then after
let's say Knight takes f7 play Queen b8
that wouldn't work because on each six
Knight f7 Queen check there's now Knight
e5 so the idea here is to make sure that
we could insert this check right now at
a moment where there isn't some
opportunity for a ninety five move and
only then give the night a kick with h6
and he's trapped and our rook has
defended everything is coordinated
really well that must be at insert the
check first addressed this potential
attack against our rook and now simply
trap the knight and it should be puzzle
solved that's going to do it
just going into the analysis board if we
do this right here the night takes
there's a double attack against our rook
and who it's actually quite tricky now
because this nights going to take up a
very strong post on e5
even though blacks up the exchange why
has a pawn for it and a really strong
night soon on e5 Queen check here 95 you
know
tricky from there move order very
important Queen here first
and only then give them a kick all
righty that wasn't too bad let's try
another team block again who some
opening huh some opening trick
I think g5 I feel like I've seen this
before
hmm all righty
there's a lot of stuff going on f7 first
and foremost is head
huh knight or bishop can take with check
there's possibilities for maybe taking
here deflecting the bishop away from the
knight maybe a see a timely see to move
deflecting the Queen away does hit with
the fork however have to be a bit
careful of something like that Queen d5
is a move like and make a queen move and
be threatening mate no let me let me
rethink this one actually can't we just
do this move yeah this is often a good
reply to this attack on f7 when we have
this Queen night out a knight on f3 he
gave up the e5 square we could play to
e5 throw a punch at the bishop and
defend f7 hmm suppose pawn takes pawn
how are we doing materialize are we just
up upon you no we're just up upon so
what would we do if 95 and then pawn
takes here that doesn't seem so
convincing it could be the idea to just
stop the threat against f7 though and we
don't have very many pieces out the pawn
Bishop Knight hmm this is a loose piece
I don't the
be a trick with Queen takes Knight
Bishop takes and then pawn takes being
on the rook the knight could move and
the Queen defends the rook hmm all
righty
this is a bit tricky I'm not sure what
other candidate move I'd have here this
seems very lame to just go and defend
the knight like that night h6 I'm
certainly looking more into this active
defense defense with throwing a punch as
well in 85 Wow what else is there
d5 what does that do after Bishop takes
here it's not working I'm not sure where
else White is weakened aside from the
bishop on c4 who's unprotected white
isn't doing so bad huh hmm I'm pretty
stumped here I can't come up with
anything other than 95 what am I missing
yeah I
after 95 pancakes here if we take the
bishop
they take our Bishop hmm han takes here
that's what it is we just take the pone
and allow let's say Bishop takes pawn
that must be what it is we have to allow
something like this well I don't know if
we have to but we're looking for what's
best maybe this is best one thing I do
know is that on pawn takes if the bishop
takes we win the knight and defend g7 I
must be what it is I can come up with
any other candidate move pawn takes
deflect the bishop away from the knight
all right let's consider some stuff on
f7 though after C takes B I know what
I'm doing on Bishop takes pawn what am i
doing on Bishop takes f7 check now just
King f7 right he only has three options
you don't want to go here you don't want
to go to e7 because you blocked the
Queen from seeing the knight so simply
King f8 keep pressure on the bishop keep
pressure on the knight and we're still
on the rook at that point yeah that's
really no big deal
a bishop takes f7 check we just screwed
our king out of the way no problem then
keep in mind we're ready to take the
rook and promote to a queen so suppose
pawn takes Bishop f7 King FA and
something I don't know semi wild like
Queen f3 threatening discoveries we can
still take the rook and some Bishop move
we could return our Queen to f6 it won't
go that far in this puzzle but just some
rough thoughts what more to cover pawn
takes pawn Knight takes f7 we could
scoop up the rook
yeah why not we take the rook get a new
queen Knight takes Queen we I don't know
I guess we could take either way at that
stage
Knight takes Knight or King takes we're
up we'd be up a minor piece and a rook
from that variation still have a queen
on the board in the corner this must be
it yep and just king def eight and now
Queen takes Knight mmm interesting yeah
it took me a while to clearly took me a
while to see that it would actually be
quite all right
to allow Bishop takes f7 check it is
just to check your king to f8 are our
punches are pretty strong with the pawn
on b2 and keeping pressure on the knight
deflecting the bishop away after that
capture I might we describe this
position well how might we describe
let's say the bishop on c1 right now and
this is so I'm kind of just going back
here how I could have maybe corrected my
thinking I was pointing out that the
bishop is unprotected that is true but
one other thing that I should have
identified maybe much sooner was that
the bishop on c1 is overloaded he has to
defend both b2 and g5 but what really
distracted me was you know trying to not
even allow a piece to crash through on
f7 okay overloaded piece just taken
advantage of with this capture alright
let's try one last one
oh I'm not going to like this one too
tricky
mmm actually I think I've had this one
before I don't know if I had it while
doing a video like this but I feel like
I've seen this before
yeah I think I had this one before
I believe it's you make a night move to
get the rook here and then you get the
Queen and rook coming in here for me
yeah I think I might end up doing a
fourth when I believe I just know the
answer and I takes f7 with rook check
here mmm hang on for a moment our queen
is also under fire let's keep that in
mind
Knight check here king of six what's the
good follow up not really seeing it and
we have to be pretty direct because if
we're going with a knight move we're
also opening up a new possibility for
black with the Queen f2 if we're not
continually throwing strong punches a
knight takes f5 pawn takes rook d7 check
what are we doing after let's say King
h6 hmm yeah I've had
but I'm not recalling what the solution
is I I know it has something to do with
this though
pretty sure I think Jake spawn we're on
the night then he's a he's a loose piece
after we take here so you have to take
back and defend Knight f5 pawn takes
Knight what else would there be besides
rook d7 I don't see it hmm the King
can't go to the back rank because we
would have Queen c8 so he has to move
forward he has to go on to the sixth
rank Knight f5 pawn takes Knight rook d7
if the King goes to any of these two
squares our Queen enters on f7 with
check and then you know crashes through
over here but what are we doing on King
h6 still not seeing that chop chop rook
d7 king h6 hmm oh you know what we might
be able to allow this check I think
might be able to allow this check on f2
so if we take take rook d7 King h6 I
think we can actually afford a quiet
move hmm with oh and this is important I
think clean g8 because there might be
some defense with the Queen coming over
here yeah this is this is a bit tricky
hmm Knight takes pawn pawn takes Knight
rook d7 check King h6 where would we go
with our Queen I'm pretty sure it's a
Queen move there I don't see how we're
improving our rook further from d7 at
that moment unmoved three chopped rook
d7 I don't see a rook move as being our
third move yeah there's no good rip move
at that point so it's a Queen move our
Queens under fire where would she go if
she goes to g8 we're threatening rook
takes h7 mate with the King being on h6
so a queen on g8 suppose Queen f2 check
King h3 where's the next check Queen f1
but after king h4 there's no good follow
up our king is actually fine on h4 and
mate will be coming up very soon however
my concern is after takes takes rook d7
king h6 Queen g8 suppose the Queen comes
over to start defending some squares
around the King offering it Queen
exchange suppose Queen g6 at that point
because I'm pretty much fine with Queen
F to move Queen g8 Queen g6
now what hmm what would we do there we
would have a queen f8 check our ruckus
on d7 our queen is on g8 and their queen
is on g6 what can we do from there
there's a check on f8 the queen is
defending h7 check on f8 hmm
you know this night's a bit of a pain
I'd like to be able to get the rook on
the 6th rank but the knight is defending
here hmm I feel that it is here at Queen
of g8 Knight takes takes rook d7 king h6
queen g8 Queen g6 hmm is there some
sneaky deflection with rook takes Queen
takes no I don't think so we're only
playing with one we're only playing with
one piece at that point let me not
forget also that okay after take stakes
here this pawn of course isn't here it's
the Queen the black Queen that is here
mm-hmm
if the knight was
here maybe a coin g5 move is available
like with this this variation of taking
on f5 rook d7 King h6 Queen g8 Queen g6
rook takes Queen takes it'd be really
nice if we could then play Queen to g5
that would be mate that would deflect
the Queen away from the g5 square but
this pesky Knight is still there to
defend g5 might there be something
related to that still kind of running
out of pieces though it's only the Queen
and rook that are the Queen rook and
maybe the f4 pawn that are contributing
to some mating net against the king yeah
this is gonna be the last one I do even
though I know I've had this one before I
sure hope that it wasn't in one of the
videos I already did my apologies if
that is the case all right Knight takes
I mean I don't see any other candidate
move am I sure about this is the first
move I'm pretty sure it's this is the
first move yeah I'm pretty sure that
this is still the first move I just
don't am I getting the third move right
take on that five they recapture rook d7
I'm pretty sure that's that's the second
move
pretty sure it's King h6 but am I
correct on Queen g8 she has some other
options right
man all right let's stuck out with Queen
g8 Queen g6 okay I'm seeing something we
could play Queen f8 check yeah we could
play queen of a check and the King has
to go here then what would we do hmm oh
we could play a we could play maybe rook
to g7 attacking the Queen and where were
the
go because she
now a very important responsibility
actually with the Queen on FAA giving
check we're forcing the King to the
fifth rank and from f8 were eyeing the
f5 pawn so we can potentially take this
pawn with check if the black Queen goes
too far away
so with this Queen f8 line King h5 rook
g7 where would the Queen go she goes to
h6 we take on f5 and it's just
collapsing yeah we'd we'd be mating from
there the knight would after block we
take the knight with the rook Queen
takes and then we made on g5 with our
Queen where would the Queen go then
after we have our rook on g7 our queen
is on f8 their king is on h5 doesn't
have too many options there's no good
check against our king suppose Queen
suppose Queen to e6 now we could take on
h7 with check and then that'll be
leading to me yeah the Queen's going to
be overloaded I think that's what it is
then after we take on their five and get
our queen to g8 go to f8 rook after this
rook g7 move there's too many
responsibilities for the black queen on
g6 to defend f5 and h7 both squares at
that stage with the King on h5 if we
take either of these pawns with either
our rook or queen
they're both hitting with check and that
should be decisive I don't think I have
to go any further that's at check oh I
hate that
that is fine let me go into the analysis
it didn't go any further with the puzzle
rook check King here Queen here's the
key move let me just double check in the
little notation that they have here it
doesn't point out any of this Queen f2
stuff but I don't think I need I don't
think I need the help of the annotation
for this because there's only one good
check here
well not a good check but there's only
one decent check I guess king h4 and
then there's nothing to do about
defending h7 so Queen f2 wasn't a fear
but after Queen here I'm almost certain
that would be that it would be Queen f8
I'm missing anything else from this
point now that I have the pieces moved I
don't think so we go to f8 King here and
now we go to g7 and this is too much
the Queen can't move and still defend
both of these two pawns yeah but both f5
and h7 can't still be defended going
here this was the mate I was referring
to they have to do these kind of blocks
and then we give me and where else is
the Queen going here we can give this
check and the King goes here we have
that mate and if he goes here we have
that okay I thought it probably would
have been better to take it out just a
little bit more with this Queen g8 and
Queen g6 to see the idea of Queen f8 and
then crook to g7 I'm pretty sure that
that's the that's how it would follow up
if it did take it out a little bit
further but maybe you could let me know
in the comments section below those of
you that are putting these to the test
against your engine of choice anyhow
feel free as usual to leave any feedback
to this video let me know how you did
did you get all three let me know in the
comments section below and as usual I
hope you got something out of it that's
all for now take care bye
you